deux secondes cette crise une petite
compilation de joe va s'amuser à aller
j'annonce la couleur on commence tout de
suite avec des bols voilà un jeu un peu
à la hotline ya mis en 2d où finalement
on doit défoncé ces gens qui sont des
soeurs de minihic eux n'ont ensuite le
parfait tiens un fils de chien je fais
quoi ah bah oui double qu'ils n'ont pas
du litige attend il ya un gars de la boa
mec de poil plus tard il avait fallu dû
allumer le bras pour ensuite tirer en
lola au revoir ouh là là attention on
attaque la un sac et je peux entrer dans
la dans la ventilation je vais toqué
oblats au plat n'a pas le temps ça fait
monter assiste aux séances de jeu niveau
tutorial terminée oui bon de monter
habilité tue tous les morts vivants mais
bien sûr
et vas-y c'est massimo c'est ma
signature de tueurs voilà évasif voilà
pardon ta gueule mais il se prend pour
un agent regarder at on va toc et ça lui
met un peu de pression attendait rien et
regarde le est barricadé comme petite
merde tu perds m'a tuer attendez donc ça
arrive on toque balle en mission
effectuée on est mort que six fois et on
a fait 8 kills ratio positif
on est maintenant sur garbage day un
jour où tout va bien à temps je
n'apparais de la jetta des gens qui
veulent me voir jouer égaler le but est
pas si je vous braque easy easy assez ça
va être voulu tuer les gens gratuitement
kouao attention une balle perdue là bas
vraiment perdu j'ai dit à la jupe une
bonne à temps mais pourquoi ils en
veulent encore mais attendez au plat au
plateau sale [ __ ] je crois juste eu des
gens ça dégage au attention couteau
perdu attention couteau perdu hop au
bâton mais fallait pas là je suis désolé
donc je dois juste tuer tous les
habitants de ce paisible endroit quoi
eva site de moi ta voiture à atur est
mort quoi oui mais attendez j'ai envie
de trop qu'ils soient tous fauchés donne
quoi
c'est drôle s'est offert et la baisse et
traverser voilà on y avait une voiture
dans l'autre sens ça va piquer mais
n'avait pas vu cela
qu'est ce qu'on s'amuse dans ce jeu ne
pas braquer une poubelle et donne-moi
tous tes déchets en balles perdues
[ __ ] ses employés ont attaqué un peu
chelou quoi brûler au soleil toute la
journée à 11 ans une danse ridicule on
balles perdues il s'ouvre pas c'est du
mensonge mensonge
c'est un coup bon sens je dois faire un
mouvement digne des plus grosses
fragmovie de mots de call of duty 367
120 bus ça non mais ça va pas c'est
[ __ ] au toujours regardé en traversant
les enfants la morale du jeu c'est ça je
crois par contre pour tuer les gens n'y
a aucun problème vous pouvez vraiment
s'attaquer aux teintes une figure des
réducs hâtif ce jeu j'adorais vraiment
oui maintenant sur go omeyer drogue
c'est une sorte de courbes plus récent
que coupe quels sont les touches
question aux caisses et les flèches du
clavier nickel j'ai fait un score de -1
ça commence extrêmement bien qu'en
france on esquive esquive n'ont pu y
aller tout aussi insupportable c'est
comme un copain nous remboursons à l'e
mail est complètement bourré [ __ ] j'ai
un jour c'est carrément anarchique
c'est un taureau [ __ ] ben voila je
fais 4 n'empêche on va ignorer les
objets maintenant on ya extrait table
mais sané mais comment je vis à vis de
musique elle me tend [ __ ] on fait les
quatre ont fait les 4 opp la 360
casse-cou vous n'avez pas vu ça on y va
on y va on y va on y va on y va on y va
mais non mais mais mais mais ça n'a
aucun sens mais c'est bien aux couples
homos à chaque touche est relié à un
membre ses intrigues dans les bordels
bois suis l'ami 4 5 il a il a été pris
d'un ya brasse basse fond il est bien
coup d'adrénaline c'était beau j'ai
commencé à totalement comprendre les
contrôles voilà en fait faut juste de
nom mais juste ce qu est possédée c'est
pour toi mais celle on a tous 13 14
oui oui est lancée comme sur des rollers
les contrôles sont rien en fait quand tu
fais une action elles se passent sept
secondes après x 1000 faut pas aller
trop vite en fait sa technique tu nous
lis pas ce qu'on voit là et on perd
comme une merde ça me rend fou je fais
ça comme s'il avait des grands cheveux
comme les filles mais pas du tout on en
tombe à l'eau
j'ai cru qu'il allait décoller carrément
intermec sur son dos et touquet valeron
de l'avion et ses blagues va trop loin
je sais que tu peux le faire je sais que
t'es pas bien tu as passé une bonne
soirée mais d'après moi je fais passer
une nouvelle soirée à cause de toi et
regarde je suis touché à rien et recule
déjà doigts c'est un petit peu le jeu
après n'est pas contre moi ça passe ça
passe ça passe ben non on est juste des
positions sexuelles bizarre quoi tu
aimes ça toi coquine à le casque n'est
pas d'accord dieu du groupe hurun
tu leur mets tu tombe pas non mais
regardez
vas-y fc - sans vie aucun problème
[Musique]
j'ai tué quelqu'un [ __ ] mais fait
quelques butin oui oui on non mais faut
qu'on passe les vases si on passe les
mains je suis content nathan mais de
quoi tu l'as vu mille fois ce carton
tutelle et déjà pris tu vas peut-être un
jour apprendre à esquiver de 7,4 qui
contenait les bières que t'as bu au bar
1 et rip à mes blagues en plus de sa fdp
ça va passer ça a passé djibril cissé
quoi ça me rendait en train de devenir
fou à la bombe du fret et des ghettos et
racketté ne serait pas sous les doigts
ça va aller ça va aller ça va allez vous
en faites pas [ __ ] mais ça va pas du
tout aller mais pourquoi on se fait des
illusions merde à la fin
fois la vérité en face lucas sait qu'une
mère du caté qu'une merde allez je ne
veux pas rester sur une défaite je mal
dormir je me mords avec alain juppé et
nous on nous donne le nom juif à chier
et frappait pourquoi le cas et j'ai
enlevé parce que cet amour il m'a fait
chier et j'arrête c'est dire autre chose
de mou ils meurent mais pourquoi tu cas
yade il fait le reste plus chez toi si
tu trouves elle veut plus toi ya patrick
sébastien nous chez toi et si tu ton il
voudra plus de toit john bien sûr qu'ils
allaient pas l'intéressé évident il y à
norton antivirus nu chez toi attention
il veut faire un plan à trois avec toi
et avast antivirus hockey et a même à
vira qui veut se mettre dans le tas et
mcafee ça n'a aucun sens allez prenez le
relais les pieds ça n'a aucun sens
le casque est sûre je viens du sud et
partout les chemins je ferais 20 et
partout les chômage est en train de
marcher une poubelle elle même une
balayette mon gars et je suis tombé par
terre j'étais vert comme les ordures
qu'elle contenait
ah bein racaille quand il fait une
blague c'est pas lui patrick sébastien
dessus à la pagaille les délégués fo que
vous défoulera zila c'est beaucoup de
chic bolt a vu et l'agencé la fin de
cette débauche de grâce à vous a plu ce
dernier m'a mis hors de moi parce que
les contrôles n'ont aucune logique en
tout cas mais ça me regarde en jetons
très hâte aux prochaines vidéos
heureusement je suis sur les nerfs je
suis tendu un peu craqué c'est je suis
désolé je demande piste
[Musique]